president Donald Trump is determined to
open American homes and businesses even
over the objections of some states when
somebody's the president of the United
States the authority is total and that's
so it's got to be total it's the state's
closed the governors of New York and
Illinois dispute that saying they want
to end shelter at home orders based on
science and they say the science isn't
clear on that yet we want to get things
back to more normal as soon as we can
but one thing that we have to pay
attention to is what direction are these
curves going and what are what is the
advice that we're getting from again the
scientists and the doctors who know more
about immunology and about you know all
the issues of kovat 19 then you know
then a an elected official who's not a
doctor in a fiery two-and-a-half hour
news conference president Trump
excoriated journalists you know you're a
fake smirk does he showed a montage of
news reports that he said underplayed
the threat of the virus and denied he
had any problem with his point man on
the pandemic even after retweeting a
Twitter post saying fire foul chi not
everybody's happy with Anthony not
everybody's happy with everybody it
happened one day after the man at the
center of the controversy
Anthony foul she said fewer people would
have died if the US administration had
acted sooner found she said that was a
poor choice of words everything I do is
voluntarily please don't even imply that
the president was especially irate over
in New York Times reports saying he
ignored warnings of the pandemic in
bumbled the early response for 80
million Americans there was good news in
the White House briefing with more of
them out of work than at any time since
the Great Depression Treasury secretary
Stephen minuchin said they could expect
long-awaited stimulus checks of up to
$1200 apiece direct deposited in their
bank accounts on Wednesday the spectacle
eclipsed the results of the Wisconsin
election an
one week after the state forced voters
to gather at polling places despite the
pandemic the man the president assailed
throughout his news conference his chief
rival Joe Biden won handily John Hendren
al-jazeera
Chicago